this is what i would give my child if
like i didn't want them
so today we're going to be watching
viral videos on australian snacks is
that a good australian accent no
and now i'm preparing my coffee
according to online instructions you
bite one corner
it's already said am i the only one that
likes the way it sounds when people chew
okay never mind i feel like we're doing
like tetris and then we just suck up
whatever hot liquid you have oh it's a
straw
that's nuts this is a revelation oh
yeah let's do it all right cheers cheers
cheers tin tam sorry
this is really good yeah
this is good yeah this is really good
it reminds me of a kitkat okay and then
the other side
what does yours look like that looks
awful
so now we dip
please don't drop in there please
you're chopping it's melting it is
melting
you all it hit it
it's gone guys
i did i didn't do it right
this is delicious with coffee though i
will have to say wait maybe we just
didn't have it cold because it oh
that is right yeah he put it in the
freezer and he poured out the fridge and
he took it out and he was like oh now
who knew then he did it okay so now we
listen to the instructions and we put
the tim tams in the freezer better than
last time right
for sure for sure oh you did what i did
last time yeah that's not gonna work
i know all right count oh norm
oh my god
oh my god it worked so i'm doing it
but it's not so fast oh yeah it's super
good i'm just gonna bite it now
[Music]
the correct way to eat vegemite
i'm scared g'day guys i'm here to show
you the correct way to eat vegemite i've
seen so many review videos of people
trying it and absolutely hating on it
but they're all eating it wrong first
get your bread all right now get your
toast done
toasted
now you want to give it a good bloody
toast too
that is perfect lather that duck with
some butter oh yeah that's the right
there get your veggie mine veggies to
apply a nice thin layer on top
is vegemite
chocolate
i don't know this looks like chicken
bouillon to me like i it looks like
something i would like add in my soup
or like my chicken or something like
that
but he's eaten it on bread all right
that right there people is
perfect it's the food of bloody
champions so don't be talking
if you're not trying it right and if you
value your life
don't bad mouth the mort okay okay so
originally
i don't really like the the the smell
that much
i'm so scared you got this
you'll be all right mike
jimmy day
[Music]
oh
scared i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared
oh my god i put so
much i have like a tear i have a tear
gee i'm so scared my hand is shaking oh
[Music]
what is this
it's salty oh
oh
what is that oh my god
yeah flour enhancer celery
celery
there is a taste of celery and i don't
like celery i love celery it does not
taste like celery
you're so funny it does not
you know he hates that i'm really
impressed that both of you actually
swallowed and ate it i still have the
piece here i could not i'll give you 10
bucks if you finish it
as an ingredient alone i'm pretty sure
that you can mix this with something and
make it pretty good so don't come all
the way first australians you know i
mean like we tried it today's menu
includes none other than the australian
classic favorite fairy bread ooh i like
her shirt first i just want to say i
love her hair and the fact that this is
fairy bread she definitely has this
ethereal purple hair look like a fairy
show me fairy bread like i'm already
feeling the vibes
butter
step two bread
bread you guys are ruining my diet
oh
step four
it's pretty cool oh no
no no no no no no no
sprinkles
and butter
okay you know i can't judge anybody's
snacks because i eat pickles and
kool-aid
i don't you know what it is i don't like
sweet and savory together i either
choose or
not at all barbecue not my friend cheers
thank you
very simple i'm excited to try that i
don't know what it's going to taste like
but
bring it on cheers
here we go
[Music]
this is good
what
i'm good i can get behind this i like it
i like it it's good it reminds me of a
snack you probably will give to your
kids this is what i would give my child
if like i didn't want them
i was like you know what go fix yourself
a meal and then the five-year-old is
like i'm gonna put sprinkles on butter
okay so the winner
oh
sometimes you take it away
i'll be flying all the way down there to
get those if they're done already yeah i
love me some tim and some tams